so let's go over the
three gross basic elements in
yesterday's technique
okay
obviously there was a huge internal
aspect to
the whole technique
and obviously you cannot separate the
elements as we're about to do
but it's easier to learn them
in a kind of microphone fashion
okay
so uh
we're going to
start
with this part we're going to cover this
part
we're
going to cover
the
yogurt part
and we're going to cover
the final pin those are the three gross
elements okay
so
from here
open
you have a c grid there
secret there
and then it closes
when you close don't close the uh
index finger
and prioritize the pinky so that
the palm is your main point of
connection watch your fingers not your
grip
okay so it's in here that you you would
have the internal aspect
on your palm okay
so home
pinky stays open
c
then pinky
each finger palm
okay and then
not in the technique but the same
mechanics is turn this a little bit just
turn it a little bit
and lift it a little bit
so that your chest can get underneath it
here
so you're going to you're comfortable
here or you're going to turn it a little
bit more and you're going to pick it up
a little bit more to match your
chest shape
turn a little bit more and pick up a
little bit more
and then you put your chest underneath
it
this hand holds
here
your thumb knuckle here
goes
inside and attacks
this thumb
at that
bone there
pushing it in
here
pinky
prioritize at the wrist joint
and the rest of the hands and the same
technique stay open so your palm is
actually what's controlling it
not your grip
palm boom bring it up
fit
hold
then we'll settle down
a little more and up
come in
on
hold
okay elbows down
don't do anything extra
no
we don't want to be in the joint anyways
yes that hurts more on the joint
but you have to be stronger than them
and he can still stab me
you don't want to do that you want to
move his body with the joint
so you don't localize the joint
hop
here
i'm getting it in place now
boom
elbows down
and i keep my chest to it it's not me
holding it here i keep my chest to it
don't pull it in here as you start to go
down it'll slip on you
keep your chest to it
[Music]
here
this is incorrect
even if i start here and it goes here
incorrect wrong
so pay attention to that
it's going up so i can get underneath it
your chest has a curvature to it there's
a curvature to it
okay and i use that curvature
i'm here
okay
this is where it goes
so don't be here don't be
on the apex of the curve let alone
underneath
on the top side of the curvature so it's
in there
on the on the upper side my clavicle
is
holding it from going over the top you
feel that bone okay it's stuck right in
there that's where it goes
next thing next mistake
no
here
this way
my wrists are straight
womb
under wrist straight watch this is weak
here like this
the two hands work together two hands
are one hand
not two hands doing two different things
next mistake your c grip's too low
too low over here
there can't be one one unit it's two
things doing two different things even
if they're complemented they're
different over here by the other hand
two hands
two hands holding the same thing
this way
so
don't close early
because you're gonna be low
get in place and use your adhesion
when you're in place that's when you
close
up
no
so usually you experience a lot of pain
as you can
okay that can't let the energy
go throughout their body
gets the localized pain
okay you're doing it
you don't have enough faith to believe
that yet
okay
and so when you experience pain just
like anybody that's been traumatized
what do you want to do back you want
other people to experience pain
you get it that's that is the technique
for you
okay but that's not the art
so
uh you start going like you start crying
you put all your oomph onto this part oh
there's some food here you're trying to
get the technique to go but you're
pulling off
the whole point was to get here the
whole point was to get here you get it
you don't want to pull it off
you do it you're here
this now becomes one unit not three
parts not two hands
but not hands and chest all is all
okay
video unified
oh
all unified unified
no no no
unify
to help you get some faith over here
like this right this is what it's doing
because your body is stronger than your
hands so you bring it to your chest or
your hair
don't stress the mechanism
do you break your own mechanism here
[Music]
make it one hand and just want don't
pull the pieces apart okay
go
so there's many variants one once you
once you have the guy's height
compromise right you can do this often
but i wanted to work on
the
stable force technique which was ikiota
this thing so we added that okay
so we when we do this
boom
here is your opening all you have to do
is turn
the mechanism and you're in place now
then the elbow goes around
remember drop the technique in the high
point is the clavicle
if you hit the apex of the curve
nipple line too low drop the nico in
don't pull it off
it's going to come off when you turn
drop it in
settle
turn the whole mechanism
the elbow is going to come to the other
hand
right there
then pull body
drop it in place
turn bring the elbow to the hand right
here
and bring his whole body don't drop his
shoulder
his whole body comes around
your thumb is going to be inside inside
his elbow not outside inside his elbow
because i have a different ending for me
note how i stay still i eat
me take on and he goes past me
don't pull this hand
this hand keeps turning
his shoulder aims down
that means i don't have to push his
elbow down
[Music]
hand turns
this has not folded it's just staying
with him he's turning
turning he's not holding this hand is
doing it
so same thing i'm not going to bring his
hand at me
bringing my chest to a
tube with a hat this is different way of
thinking about it okay so in the
technique right i bring his hand out
here look it's on my chest
i don't go wherever i want
and then
you're moving the wrong thing
okay
so same thing
wall
here
i go
and you want to get that elbow but right
here you open everything up
instead cave the knee
you see it's still on right
and now it goes off
you see
and then this elbow is going to come to
the other hand as i dismantle the
technique
don't reach
it's going to work
there it is
[Music]
here
don't worry it's gonna get there
there it is
just like the item
don't pull it off your chest you're
going to lose all control go
this hand is not
pulling
down
okay
i'm moving inside this circle over here
i'm going to move inside this circle
over here who goes around here
you see everything's you're all doing
everything in the wrong hand
the other hand
okay
here
here like this
is here like
whom
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
because
i want to keep the fingers
at the right angle
to his wrist
i don't want to do this
because it's very hard to turn now okay
here
right angle if you open it
leave it here
this these hands are almost pushing into
each other to keep the right angle
whoa
so they end up
at the 90 and at no point do they break
that 90.
you see the 90 90
keep the 90
90.
opening this
okay
try it again uh
this this version
you're coming around
and
it's not ekyo or
or i'm gonna square up
i'm gonna not let it settle at the
bottom
okay so it's gonna go around
to where this elbow
is on the front side of my spine line
by continuing its spiral okay
so
all
this way
right there
is that part
around
right into place
okay
the ending
here
bicep
in the palm
to twist
this
this way
elbow as i said
front hemisphere
not
midline definitely not back that is
totally wrong okay
front hemisphere he wants to do that you
don't let him do that you see
so it comes up
and you grab
and it's locked in place
and then the other hand
is to make sure that the elbow stays on
the front hemisphere you're not holding
his arm it's keeping it in place so like
a violin go all the way across
boom
and then anchor it
then don't twist your body
push his elbow with your center
boom
there it is right in place
okay
he wants to do that no no no
so i'm coming home this way
secure it
draw across
in then secure it
and you bow this elbow forward like the
kimura
here no
okay
three common mistakes
you come around
[Music]
and
you're going to
pass the technique
come back around on the spiral and then
try to do the technique so you see how i
ended up over here
uh be strong
and you're not going to get it
it's also not controlled maintenance so
you don't
pass the technique he comes around
boom and it goes on he was going that
way it goes that way we'll do that same
side
okay
it's not going to pass it
back around and then do it
right when it drops in place
it goes to this control point
boom right angle
okay
second mistake
you pull him up
like this it's a pin
it
so you're is to settle
settle
not pull him up
pins do not go up
it goes down down down down
that causes the third mistake
generally
[Music]
in
western region people
is
you go like this on your feet
this way
okay you're trying to get low but you
can't actually stand back up
and you should always
be able
low
but you can stand back up
okay
don't confuse the mechanical
with
an energetic
cheese settling okay go